samsung a présenté cette année déjà deux
tablettes il ya la galaxy tab a fait
plus de l'entrée de gamme la galaxy tab
est 5e qui est du milieu de gamme c'est
la s5 essentiels qui marche bien et
toute nouvelle tablette que je vous ai
présenté l'autre jour lors d'un
événement à paris c'est la galaxy tab s6
c'est le haut de gamme de ce que sait
faire samsung sur les tablettes modèle
sympa maintenant la question c'est à qui
s'adresse cette galaxy tab à 6 est ce
qu'elle est satisfaisante
est ce qu'elle est intéressante et si
vous devez vous positionner pour quelles
raisons
[Musique]
samsung innove pour poste en mal de
choses et c'est vrai que c'est
intéressant le marché la tablette est un
peu compliqué un peu beaucoup compliqué
parce que on n'achète pas vraiment de
table est d'autant plus que les
smartphones deviennent de plus en plus
grand au détriment des tablettes où je
sais pas si vous vous avez une tablette
c'est le capable de marquer en bas en
commentaires si vous en avez une
pourquoi est-ce que vous avez une
tablette et quels sont les usages avec
et si vous n'en avez pas pourquoi vous
n'en avez pas est ce que c'est juste une
question financière dont l'or est
ouvrier je ne veux pas acheter de
tablettes pour moi ça n'a strictement
aucun intérêt
j'ai un double au en gros avec mon
smartphone juste une question de
dimension des grandes marques et moi
tout ça et moi ce que vous en pensez
et puis si vous comptez en acheter une
pourquoi comment quels sont vos besoins
vous attendent comme ça on verra si
cette tablette en tout cas cause toutes
les caches
on verra ça c'est dur à dire on verra
cette tablette koch toutes les cases à
la foudre à melun en ce sens oui ou en
tout cas elle est plutôt cool alors elle
a des trucs qui sont vraiment vraiment
vraiment vraiment cool ça j'avais déjà
vu lorsque j'avais rencontré que vous
avez emmené avec moi à paris sur une
péniche
mais elle a aussi des trucs voilà qui
sont un peu moins bien en faire un tour
est ce qu'on saute pour dire ce que vous
en pensez
je vous fais un tour il fait riper
réparé rapide de la boîte pour vous
montrer ce qui à l'intérieur envoya la
tablette ça le style et jusque là je
pense que vous en douterez vous allez
avoir ici dans cette partie de quoi
ouvrir votre tireurs de cartes sims tout
pour ajouter l'extension de mémoire
parce que moi c'est une version wifi il
existe une version wifi une version 4g
mais ça je vous explique à la fin et si
vous avez des écouteurs qui vont venir
se brancher en usb c'est ici pas de
prise jack sur tablette donc vos formes
présentées d'écouteurs vous avez des
mines qui sont juste là votre câble usb
usb c est si votre bloc de charge
voilà c'est assez standard première
chose de ce mois vous parlez de la
prison d'un mois je te casse une
tablette qui est intéressante parce
qu'elle n'est pas très grande patronne
bonne prise en main assez légères assez
fine format qui coule 16/10 durement
pendant quelques instants
c'est vrai qu'elle est bien elle fait
son poids mais vu la répartition et vu
qu'on l'apprend demain ça pose
absolument pas de souci on un dos en alu
qui est sympa ce que je fais un petit
peu regretté
et voilà c'est un petit peu le point
négatif c'est le positionnement ici
alors on va se dire effectivement c'est
cool
vous avez une petite marque là vous avez
la même soit votre style et espère qu on
appelle ça ici vous venez le positionner
il est bien il se recharge directement
ici donc ça c'est bien
maintenant il ya un gros point négatif
avec ça c'est que lorsque vous prenez en
l'état qui vous le mettez dans un sac
eh bien ça se décrochent tout simplement
parce qu'effectivement il est aimanté
donc dès lors que vous le positionner et
cas une contrainte physique d'envoyer up
bon je vous fais un peu la partie mais
sa part donc dans un sac c'est embêtant
donc il vous faut soit que vous le
métier à côté que vous ne leur charge et
pas dans votre sac soit que vous aviez
un étui dédié qui va venir effectivement
incorporer le stylet pour qu'il puisse
ne pas partir mais pourquoi c'est un peu
le point négatif c'est à fort astucieux
mais à la fois un peu con d'autant plus
que lorsque vous le prenez et que vous
le posez sur une top pair avec le stylet
est bien oubliée on n'est pas très très
bien alors quand il y recharger tout va
bien mais lorsque vous voulez le
recharger et utilisées en même temps il
faut forcément le prendre à la main ou
alors être plus avoir une étude dédiée
sinon voilà c'est là un taux le bât
blesse point positif vous avez un
capteur d'empreintes digitales or c'est
un capteur optique
vous n'avez pas du tout ici un capteurs
ultrasoniques néanmoins up reviendra mon
lapin néanmoins il marche bien
d'un point de vue purement esthétique on
retrouve ce qu'on a mis sur la table et
5e qui a fait son succès un design
simple efficace et qui marche
parfaitement bien dans l'époque y avait
une vraie belle réussite en tout cas
c'est son écran vous avez un écran super
amoled 2560 par 1600 pixels format 16/10
c'est différent parce que sur les
smartphones
on évolue 18/9 on se rapproche du vin 9e
21 ne viennent là on est sûr eu 16 10e
s'est allongée mais ça marche pas mal
diagonale de 10 points 5 pouces
compatibles hdr1 d'écran qui occupent
85% de la face avant je le trouve assez
lumineux là je vous le pousse à fond il
est bien pour gagner en extérieur ça
fonctionne plutôt bien c'est pas ce qui
va être le plus dingue mais franchement
ça marche plutôt bien
écran bien calibré de bonne qualité je
trouve vraiment cool et une fois de plus
hauts annuels pour venir filtrer la
lumière bleue je vous le conseille
franchement je vous le conseille vous
avez aussi un mode nuit si vous
souhaitez si vous aimez ça permettra de
consommer moins de batterie bon à vous
de voir ça c'est vraiment des choix vous
avez mode d'écran soins naturels soient
vifs je vous conseille le mode naturel
qui est franchement beau
plus doux et beaucoup mieux à côté de ça
c'est one day ça marche bien c'est
pratique c'est sympa on voit donc on a
un écran qui est top et le côté
multimédia pour regarder vos séries vos
films netflix youtube d'amazon ce que
vous voulez tout ce que vous voulez ça
marche bien c'est bien et en plus un qui
est vraiment intéressant et ça je peux
que vous le recommander si vous avez
quatre haut parleurs vous avez quatre
haut parleurs mais vous avez de la
stéréo c'est un peu le point le point
bas rhin faisait donc haut parleurs ici
et ici et de l'autre côté haut parleurs
ici et 6 haut parleurs signé à cacher si
vous le savez pas à kg a été racheté par
samsung donc ça nous permet donc d'avoir
des hauts parleurs de bonne qualité mais
il ya un effet qu'il vachement cool et
sens où elle explique effectivement lors
de la vidéo de présentation du produit
c'est que lorsque vous regardez un film
comme ça et bien vous avez une source
thériault les deux haut parleurs de ce
côté là vont marcher ensemble pour vous
donner du sont là et une bonne
stéréoscopie qui donne de ce cocktail
vous avez donc une bonne stéréoscopie
mais lorsque vous ramenez votre pas bête
comme ça et que votre film où votre
série vous le regardez dans ce format là
et bien vous n'avez pas du sang qui est
là et du son qui est là au contraire une
bonne répartition c'est là que c'est
intelligent il une bonne adaptation et
bien les deux haut parleurs qui sont de
ce côté là en haut et en bas vont
fonctionner de concert et cela
exactement de la même manière ce qui
vous permet d'avoir quoi qu'il se passe
côté stéréo adaptatif qui est vachement
bien quelle que soit la voie dans
laquelle vous allez tourner votre
tablette
et du coup vous avez du songe tout info
en sont vraiment les quatre quarts alors
qu'ils marchent en même temps c'est
vraiment hyper agréable pour me regarder
du contenu multimédia
donc ça cette première usage de cette
tablette c'est à dire grand écran
multimédia haut parleurs multimédia
pouvez donc l'utiliser pour venir
regarder du contenu très facilement et
donc sur une excellente tablette pour ça
après vous allez vous dire j'ai pas posé
700 800 euros pour venir regarder du
contenu multimédia je peux avoir avec
une table est 5e qui coûtera moins cher
voire une tabac
c'est une certitude donc qu'est-ce que
je peux encore faire avec ces petites
bêtes
vous pouvez donc jouer à des jeux jouent
à des jeux hyper faty si asphalte neuf
mais il ya aussi plein d'autres jeux il
pratiquera il fera il profitera cool
faut savoir derrière vous avez instinct
dragon 855 ici pas d'exil hausse mais
hop ça marche
vachement bien c'est très très cool vous
avez 8 gigas de ram 256 go de stockage
extensible jusqu'à 512 giga selon ce que
nous dit effectivement samsung et vous
pourrez monter jusqu'à 2 tera avec des
cartes haute que les cartes sont donc là
je vous parle que d'eux
mieux vaut le faire plein d'autres
choses bien évidemment vous avez vous
pouvez aussi avoir de jeu beaucoup plus
puissants beaucoup plus performants
qu'ils demanderont plus de ressources qu
un asphalte 9 vous faire tourner pas mal
de thé dessus donc vous êtes vraiment
tranquille est vraiment conformez vous
pouvez aller plus loin en termes de
productivité avec toutes ces puissances
pouvaient faire tourner des applications
diverses et variées faire du multitâche
on est donc sur une tablette qui va
avoir un petit peu je dirais bureautique
domestique d'autant plus que vous pouvez
la voir avec la smart cover que je n'ai
pas je n'ai pas testé mais que je vous
ai montré lors de la présentation que
vous venez connectés ici en dessous qui
en plus se referment et de la protéger
ce qui d'ailleurs est plutôt pas mal et
non négligeable vous avez donc cette
smart cover qui vous servent de clavier
vous le passez en mode d'aix l'utiliser
comme un petit pc comme un petit
ordinateur
donc pour faire de la bureautique
familiale du multitâche ça marche c'est
pratique alors après vous n'allez pas
avoir non plus regain de puissance de la
lever 8 gigas de ram vous allez pouvoir
faire du photoshop par exemple c'est
tout l'intérêt avec ce s pen là de
pouvoir revenir l'utiliser pour ce que
vous êtes par exemple illustrateur
infographiste vous pouvez travailler
architecte faire des dessins de la prise
de notes mais attention on n'a pas
énormément de puissance donc si vous
êtes sous photoshop on va pas faire
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de calques
n'oubliez pas 8 gigas de ram on est
quand même que sera sa dragonne 855 même
s'il marche bien donc il ya des choses
qu'on va pouvoir faire on va pouvoir
faire plein de choses mais pas aller
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup trop loin
après falloir switcher sur un pc ou sur
un max vous voulez on rend plus de
performances mais déjà comme elle est là
en l'état pour de la bureautique
familiale pour la prise de notes pour du
dessin pas mal le choc vous pouvez y
aller vous êtes vraiment tranquille
qu'est ce que tu dirais tous les goûts
mais j'ai tout donné
toi ou tu plus que moi tu es mon fils tu
es bien mieux que moi et latin kavala en
échec le manteau maintenant je peux y
aller un très bon hockey
bon je peux y aller autonomie qui est
correct alors après ça dépend toujours
bien évidemment de vos usages madrid
7040 millan terreur on dit on a une
grosse batterie donc on pourra y aller
au tacos attention grosse batterie mais
aussi grand écran qui va consommer
davantage alors effectivement si vous le
passez en mode nuit sondé sur deux super
amoled pouvait sur technologie oled
aucun pixels noirs de pixels éteinte ce
qui veut dire que si vous passez en mode
nuit et bien vous allez consommer
beaucoup moins ça va dépendre de vos
usages
samsung nous donne 14 heures d'autonomie
met bout à bout ça dépendra bien
évidemment de vous de vos visages je
vais pas comptait un nombre de jours
comme sur un smartphone parce que c'est
pas la même chose parce qu'on va pas
être tout le temps tu toute la journée
mais voilà je pense qu'une bonne dizaine
d'heures en tout cas vous êtes sans
problème pour la partie photo vous avez
un double module photo à l'arrière ce
qui d'ailleurs plutôt pas mal mais pas
complètement dingue vous avez un premier
de 13 mégapixels et une ouverture de f
2.0 sans équivalent vingt-six
millimètres brossé l'appareil photo
standard normal qui marche bien et vous
n'avez un deuxième 5 mégapixels qui
ouvre à f 2.2 qui valent en 13 mm donc
un ultra grand angle
tandis qu'à l'avant vous avez ici une
petite caméra de celle fille qu'il
cachait légèrement ici c'est une 8
mégapixels très clairement on pas
utiliser cette tablette pour faire des
photos c'est pas son rôle premier de
l'année sur le capteur de 13 mégapixels
ça marche pas mal
légèrement sursaturé lorsqu'on regarde
comme ça directement à l'écran par
rapport à ce qu'on peut voir dans la
réalité mais c'est assez bien le détail
est juste le rendu de qualité samsung
maîtrise et photos ça marche bien même
capteur ça marche bien
là où ils sont l'ultra j'entends que
c'est un peu moins bien on va perdre un
petit peu on a un peu moins saturé c'est
un peu moins juste un peu moins d'un
bond de l'autre côté on n'est pas sur un
truc de fou ce travail photo avec le
capteur principal qui marche bien rendu
plutôt pas mal malgré toi c'est naturel
l'ultra grand angle qui est pas
complètement dingue mais qui fait son
petit effet lorsque vous avez beaucoup
lumière et la caméra de sel film je vous
parlais pas de photos de nuit je vais
pas rentrer trop dans le détail parce
que c'est pas son adn
on est sur une tablette on est sur un
objet qui a pas mettre de faire
peut-être des photos sur deux trois
petits détails venir ajouté griffonnait
la note dessus mais on n'est pas sur un
photo tablette fait c'est pas que mon
peuple et ça mais on n'est pas là pour
immortaliser des souvenirs comme on
pourrait le faire avec son smartphone
point qui est très
est positif et hyper important c'est le
s pen que vous allez utiliser comme sur
la gamme note les nouveaux noter les
notes de cette année note 19 10 puces
vous avez les airs jester peut venir
naviguer entre vos différents modes hop
on va passer sur la caméra de l'autre
côté et voyez on va l'utiliser comme ça
comme vous voulez pour faire ce que vous
voulez c'est vraiment pratique vous
appuyer une fois vous faites une photo
vous appuyé deux fois vous switchez de
côté vous faites ce que vous voulez et
ça c'est vraiment cool alors sur votre
stylet vous allez pouvoir faire aussi
beaucoup beaucoup de choses si vous
utilisez votre respect de créer une note
affichée les notes la sélection
intelligente de la capture massage animé
ar doodle de la traduction qui est donc
pas mal de possibilités on la respecte
beaucoup n'est pas à la traîne par
rapport à ce qu'on peut avoir sur la
gamme note de cette année c'est vraiment
bien pour coup c'est vraiment
intéressant donc si vous hésitiez a
acheté un galaxy 2 10 uniquement pour
avoir ça que vous n'avez pas forcément
besoin que vous préfériez le format
tablette c'est possible ça peut vous
arriver
et bien sachez qu'avec ça vous allez
souffrir d' absolument rien donc ça
c'est vraiment intéressant et je vous
dis une fois plus le truc que j'ai
regretté ses complices pas arrangé le
espagne directement ici est-ce que ce s
pen est un petit peu trop gros est ce
qu'il faudrait en espagne plus petits
comme ce qu'on peut retrouver sur la
note 10 9 10 plus et qu'on puisse venir
le ranger directement dedans je pense
que ça aurait un sens alors après
effectivement les sur les tablettes qui
est extrêmement fine qui ne le permet
pas mais surtout cas pour moi là où vous
retrouverez le meilleur usage alors bien
évidemment on va falloir faire un
compromis entre la finesse et le
rangement du fpeg
voilà ça je laissais samsung le le soin
de choisir mais c'est vrai qu'en tout
cas ça aurait été le truc idéal une
tablette fine un style et confort ni
rangée de dents voilà on fait pas non
plus de la magie mais dans l'absolu ça
serait bien on en plus de ça une
technologie wacom avec 4096 niveau de
pression différents enfin voilà et un
stylet qui ne sert pas de gadgets qui
est vraiment là si vous êtes si vous
voulez faire de la prise de notes du
dessin d'illustration ça vous servir à
ça c'est vraiment très pratique je sais
pas ce que vous en pensez vous moi je la
trouve cool ça va vous avez aussi bien
évidemment du wifi ses dix bougies 5 pas
de wifi si si si du bluetooth 5.0 ça
marche bien j'ai encore le sens pour me
reposer
voilà il est posé il aimante et il est
bien voyez le truc c'est que bon voilà
pour effectivement voilà ça va dépendre
de commandes à lescouët c'est un peu un
peu le point négatif effectivement si
vous le prenez que vous balader avec
votre stylet et bien normalement vous
n'allez pas le perdre il va pas
tombé là oui c'est quand même assez
résistant par contre s'il ya des gestes
qui sont un peu plus sauvage voilà c'est
un peu plus embêtant mais bon une fois
de plus on n'est pas là pour le jeter de
tous les côtés je cherche vraiment à le
tester un peu dans ses retranchements
je trouve que c'est en tout cas un des
point négatif c'est à la fois bien la
fin de positif parce qu'effectivement
bien vous embêtez pas vous le prenez
vous le posez mais je vous dis une fois
de plus qu'on va lui poser sur une table
voilà c'est un petit peu moyen s'il faut
poser sur la face avant vous risquez de
l'oreiller donc il faut une protection
si vous avez la smart cover c'est idéal
c'est encore mieux mais il faut poser
encore plus d'argent
voilà donc il ya plein de choses qui
soit pas en mettant à sac le style est
quand même est inclus dans donc ça c'est
ça c'est couleurs on va parler du prix
justement le prix il est là sandra
fiches de notes
si vous achetez la version wifi coûte
799 euros on est tout de suite sur les
tarifs assez élevés on est sur un
produit très haut de gamme au niveau de
la tablette et si vous la version 4g
wifi 869 euros c'est pas gratuit ça
coûte un peu d'argent mais à côté de ça
vous avez un très beau produit humala
cite une cible familiale qui fait de la
bureautique familiale qui aiment prendre
des notes ou qui veut pouvoir dessiner
ou pourquoi pas le laisser un enfant
pour s'amuser je sais ça fait beaucoup
d'argent pour les cernant ça pour
s'amuser mais ça pourrait me faire
plaisir
donc voilà je trouve intéressant car si
vous cherchez une tablette sous android
haut de gamme qui marche bien avec plein
de performance celle là elle est
vraiment top si vous voulez un peu moins
de performance mais un très beau produit
que le style est pas forcément votre
dada
la table est 5e sera parfaitement bien
et si vous voulez juste une tablette
sous android pour regarder des séries et
pas plus et à tabac marche bien mais
celle là elle est exigeante lé coup je
trouve bien voilà vous de me dire ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
comment vous la trouvez cette galaxy tab
s6 intéressante oui non pas comment et
par rapport aux questions du début est
ce qu'au final elle rentre dans vos
critères par rapport à ce que vous
pourriez éventuellement acheter par
rapport à ce que vous avez déjà vous
marquez tout ça en bas en commentaire et
quant à nous on se retrouve dès demain
salut alliotte où tu dis pas au revoir
au revoir au revoir il est timide
allez bisous de macho